you look fantastic wow thank you very
much you know it's a part of my
philosophy yes is it really yes as the
face gets worse the clothes have to get
better
an amazing thing i just realized when
when johnny carson was hosting the
tonight show right i guess hosted about
six times which makes us even
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
i think you're laughing a little too
hard oh yeah that's and crying
at the same time beautiful studio isn't
it nice yeah it's really great yeah we
didn't assume there's a that's an actual
piece of moon rock back there yeah it's
a little large
it looks like we're being attacked yes
it is it's here it can loom forward at
any point to attack you uh so much to
talk about first of all
rare bird alert this is getting rave
reviews from very serious uh musical
journals yes exactly thank you and
i uh the it is interesting because the
the bluegrass magazines are now calling
me the ambassador of the five string
banjo it was uh it was between me and no
one
really there's no one else in there
really okay that's that's sad uh now
you're
this is very exciting for you i'm told
we have a photograph here of the first
time that they handed you is that right
the the the actual package the action is
exciting when you get uh when you first
get this is you when you first saw the
cd
never seen any adult male that happy
about anything
yeah that's the uh you know that's the
that's the cd
that's very exciting but you know they
make records now in all kinds of forms
this is the the vinyl
oh that's right yeah they make audio
files uh like this it's a vinyl and it's
beautiful you can open it up it's got
all the things liner notes and all that
yeah yeah and it also comes
in
an eight track
[Laughter]
yes a lot of people are insisting now
that it come in eight-track eight-track
and this is a new one for me i had never
seen this before this is a convenient
suppository
that's
that's fantastic thank you that's
that's great why are you
why are you
why
i'm not quite sure i think you hear it
in your head
may hold on to this yeah you can yeah
yeah
that's how it works yeah i'll let you
know i'm going to give you the first one
i call um
speaking of music you've gotten you
always played uh music was a big part of
your life but you you've gotten really
into it in the last couple of years and
you and i are something in common which
is we both played bonnaroo that's last
year last year there was a 110 degrees
it's a bonnaroo in case you don't know
what it do you know what it is
yeah
huge music festival huge music festival
it was 100 degrees
and uh it was very exciting to play
there the
fantastic enthusiastic audience it was a
thrill i mean it was a thrill
for me to play there and i heard that
you you know you were playing at the
same time so it was exciting just to
know that we were there together yeah
absolutely absolutely fantastic yeah you
know i'm a little i'm bummed out that
there was no i just i'd love it just a
photograph of you and i together you
know there's a record there's a record
of it are you have you seen the youtube
video there's a youtube video of both of
us absolutely
absolutely do you have the youtube video
here yes maybe they do
the wild party at bottom those are good
times
i am so uh sorry though i didn't get to
see your show oh well i'm sorry i didn't
want to see yours either
you're a bad bad man
uh i'm actually a good man you're a good
man
i didn't realize that you're a very good
man who does bad things yeah yeah there
you go thank you andy you're welcome
thank you
i'm getting caught in the middle here
has did your show uh
evolve much the show that that
that i did with andy that we went out
and i noticed that it changed a lot from
the first show to the last show it went
through a lot you know i used to do
stand-up comedy i do an hour and a half
of stand-up comedy and uh wow and um
[Applause]
[Laughter]
and now i do a music show with comedy
and so it's always changing and in fact
i you know i'm constantly making notes
and then someone found my discarded
notes and they posted it
on the web and it was interesting to see
these are notes from about a year ago
and it was interesting to go back over
my old notes and see
what i had written
for example these are the notes they're
just
xerox copies but like this note i
thought was interesting it says
audience seems to love it when i show up
that's very good yeah it was interesting
yeah
here's another one
explain that blue grass is not a great
new strain of pot
this is very helpful yeah
i thought this this this was a good
comment and i and i followed this advice
cut lecture on credit card fraud
uh here's here's another note note to
self
don't forget three
in song count off to four
this is just a good general note if
those groupies rush the tour bus again
gently turn their walkers back around
the same problem